Film Courage: What is subplot?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: Hmmm…what is subplot?
I would say a true subplot is any plot separate
from or plot line separate from the A-story
that has its own sort of goal and through
line right?
So the through line is going to be created
by the pursuit of the goal?
So it could be your protagonist with another
goal that they are trying to pursue I guess
that’s maybe the most common example that
we could pull up would be your character is
trying to rob a series of banks and then there
is a romantic subplot so he is also trying
to have a romantic relationship with someone
who has nothing to do with the banks right
it’s its own goal that has its own arc through
the movie so I would call that a true subplot.
You could also have a subplot that is driven
by another character so your protagonist is
robbing a series of banks unbeknownst to him
or known to him his brother is trying to win
custody of his child.
So separate goal, it’s going to have it’s
own arc in the story.
It probably won’t have equal weight (that’s
why we call it a subplot right) because you
want your focus to be on the A-story but it
will have its own there is a separate goal
that is being pursued that has its own through
line.
Film Courage: Why do we need subplot?
Naomi: I think you could argue that not all
stories, not all movies need subplots right?
Sometimes we watch movies and it just feels
like everything is connected to that A-story
and we don’t really have true separate subplots
but depending on the affect that you’re
trying to achieve and the sort of takeaway
message that you’re trying to give with
your story sometimes a subplot can compliment
that.
I’m trying to think of a good example?
I feel like in Jerry Maguire the Rod Tidwell
getting his new offer from the team or whatever
(it’s been awhile since I’ve seen the
movie) but I feel like that was a true subplot
because it was (if I remember right) it was
Jerry trying to get an offer for his client
so it would have been Jerry’s sort of separate
goal…is that right?
Now I don’t remember.
Film Courage: And I think he really needed
Rod because he was like his biggest client?
So it was kind of a stakes thing too?
Naomi: Now I am confusing myself so I’m
not sure if that’s right?
But I think that’s true so I think the subplot
was he’s trying to get a deal or an offer
for Rod Tidwell from Arizona his current team.
That subplot was necessary to Jerry Maguire’s
story because it compliment his learning that
lesson of the theme which is that you have
to plea with heart.
You have to stop being calculated and strategic
sometimes and just put your whole heart into
it.
I think you can look at subplots as helping
to again teach your protagonist the lesson
that they need to learn from these series
of events…so Jerry gets fired and he starts
his own company and his romance with Dorothy
I think is a subplot because that’s a separate
goal.
He is having a…they very much overlap and
sometimes they happen in the same scenes right
where there are these two plot lines being
pushed forward at the same time but starting
his business and making it a success…gosh
now that I’m thinking of that the Rod Tidwell
thing might have been part of that and then
the subplot of the romance would be a separate
storyline.
That would be the romantic subplot that he
is pursuing.
Film Courage: So can a film have many subplots?
Naomi: Yes.
Film Courage: Oh they can, okay.
Naomi: I definitely think so and I think that
how much weight a subplot has can vary greatly.
Like you can have a romance subplot that is
nearly equal with the A-story or you can have
something that ends up looking like a runner
through your script.
Maybe it is a minor goal that the character
is pursuing but we only need to see three
or four scenes where it’s like introduced
- pursued - and then accomplished (or whatever).
So I think you can have lots of subplots.
My caution about having subplots would be
careful that our focus stays on the A-story
because if you have too many subplots and
you’re not keeping our focus on that main
storyline like that main conflict that we
are watching it can end up feeling like we
don’t know which story we’re supposed
to be paying attention to.
It can feel sort of scattered so that’s
the only thing I would say to be careful of
but most people are when they come at writing
a screenplay they have a pretty good sense
of what that main story that they’re trying
to tell.
Film Courage: Well because…is it Dorothy
who is the Renée Zellweger character?
Because she has her own subplot in that (and
I don’t even know if you’d call it that)
but that she is living with her sister and
her sister is maybe like a divorcee and older
and maybe a little more bitter and the great
scene of Renée and Tom coming into the women’s
group and they all just shoot these daggers
at Tom and he’s trying to prove that he’s
a good guy.
And that against all odds that he is this
good guy and she has this sister character
who is real doubtful and just trying to fight
against that.
So you see Renée and her situation and I
don’t know if that is also a subplot?
Naomi: Well so I would say that you could
look at the subplot…Renée Zellweger (Dorothy)
has her the romance subplot we look at it
from her point of view as well so we actually
see that relationship from both points of
view.
I would say that her relationship with her
sister is just a relationship and it’s not
its own subplot because Renée isn’t necessarily
pursuing anything, I don’t think her sister
is either?
There isn’t really a goal that we’re sort
of seeing the goal established and then seeing
them pursue it and conflict and then resolution
right?
So I would call that a relationship with a
supporting character and I would say that
that supporting character is one of the benefits
of the sister is that she helps Dorothy reflect
on what she really wants in life, the sort
of role of love in her life, how much she
needs and how much she is willing to settle
for right which is still in that same thematic.
Question for the viewers: Would you ever write
a movie that had zero subplots?